many people didn't understand me growing
up
it got me to the place where i just
wanted to disappear from the world
i just wanted to be understood i just
wanted to be a part of the world
dad that's that for me
my name is antoine hunter i'm a director
dancer artist
and also i'm deaf
we who are deaf
we can feel the vibration
we love all kinds of music for which i
wanted to feel it
whatever you want to play just play it
out
i take home the music i get my speakers
playing it close to me really really
loud
and i memorized it to my body i thought
when i moved that vibration that's in my
body stay to me
i teach with a deaf students
we work with deaf people when i'm
signing
and teaching and know how to get their
attention to move to this side or that
one
it's awesome for them and it's awesome
for me
it becomes a place where they feel
accepted and i feel rejected or ignored
oh i'm deaf and i can be that
when i'm taking in class for my deaf men
this will be the fourth year burial
deaf international dance festival
i was the director and the founder of it
i realized my responsibility to
make a platform
for a deaf artist to be presented to the
world
this performance gives them a real
state
a real audience and real speaker because
now we need a loud
i would like to stay i have a lot to
share
i don't want to be in a place where i
can't express myself
i want to share the truth
you